Whether you like it or not, we all have limits.
Limits with regard to energy, time, and focus.
This is really important to keep in mind, especially with respect to social media,...
...and I want to give a little bit of context here.
For at least hundreds of thousands of years,...
...humans were hunter-gatherers that lived in small groups.
Estimates vary on the size of these groups, but on average, it's about 150.
There are a number of reasons why the number caps out there.
And one of the main ones is the fact that...
...we're just unable to create quality relationships with trust...
...and depth beyond that number.
I mean, it makes sense.
It takes a long time to get to know someone.
In fact, I'm not even close to having 150 really deep relationships,...
...and I'm perfectly okay with that.
However, I really like that number...
...and I think it's not a bad idea at all to cap the number of people that you follow...
...on any given social media platform at a 150.
The thing is, we go throughout our lives accumulating.
Let me ask you, why is it that your email inbox fills up with spam?
It's because we sign up for the different events, offers, deals,...
...depending on our interests at different stages of life.
And honestly, the same exact thing happens with people.
They come in and out of our lives.
And you know what?
At best, most of these people are just background characters in your life.